which one is he saying oh that I'm four
years WNBA star Lisa Leslie has had Kobe
Bryant's Jersey on display in her home
but since his death it's taken on a
special meaning he would not be that's
for sure they met when Bryant was only
18 years old before his rookie season
with the Los Angeles Lakers and Leslie's
debut with the sparks the two quickly
became rising stars in LA basketball and
grew close what do you remember about
when you first met him I would go to the
house and he's like Lee's please Mike
what please come here come here watch
this watch this so he's always he's
watching Jordan videos Michael Jordan
video Jordan he's clicking the pause
look look look Lee's white white so he
studied Michael Jordan's beyond study I
mean he would like obsess over watching
these videos he imitated everything
Jordan did they watched Kobe's
interviews like the way he talks the way
he moves his mouth when he licks his
lips when he puts his tongue out when he
played everything was about Michael
Jordan and that's the player that meant
everything to him and he wanted to be
great not good but great like Michael
Jordan when people say arrogant aloof
that's not what you remember about him I
know it's so interesting arrogance there
is arrogance absolutely but the
arrogance is not in everyday life the
arrogance is in the world of basketball
on the basketball court you said asked
about go no you're not my friend and I'm
not your friend and it's either kill or
be killed
I'm gonna attack you I'm going for the
juggler at all times
what does Kobe's death what does his
loss mean to women's basketball you know
he was really making change was he yes
he's changing the mindsets of other men
more than anybody else he's giving us
he's validating us if you will these
young ladies who are out there playing
the fact that he's enjoying and being in
her
by great basketball it made other men
feel I'm hoping like what is this about
like this is it's good I've heard that
sometimes he would spend more time at
WNBA games now than he would at the
Lakers games true it's true but I think
it's also because GG wanted to see
certain players and she was into it and
he talked about just you know I remember
seeing him he was like please she got it
she got it you know he was just she got
it
it's tough Lisa looking at the pictures
of him and GG together playing
basketball
sitting on the sidelines it really does
take your heart and rip it out when I
see those pictures we know what Kobe's
accomplished but GG hadn't she didn't
have the full opportunity to do that
because you just know that she she had
the myth the the mentality mamasita was
gonna make it she was going to be in the
WNBA it's been said that his legacy is
complicated because of sexual assault
charge which was dismissed in 2003 2004
is it complicated for you as a woman as
a WNBA player it's not complicated for
me at all even if there's a few times
that we've been at a club at the same
time Kobe's not the kind of guy never
been like you know at least go get that
girl or tell her or send her this
I have other NBA friends that are like
that Kobe's he was never like that I
just never see have ever seen him being
the kind of person that would be do
something to violate a woman or be
aggressive in that way that's just not
the person that I know but Lisa you
wouldn't see it though as his friend you
wouldn't see it and that's possible
mm-hmm I just it's just I just don't I
just don't believe that and I'm not
saying things didn't happen I just don't
believe that things didn't happen with
force is it even a fair question to talk
about it considering he's no longer with
us and that it was resolved or is it
really part of his history I think
that the media should be more respectful
at this time it's like if you had
questions about it you've had many years
to ask him that I don't think it's
something that we should keep hanging
over his legacy I mean he went to it
went to trial
yeah but the cases it was dismissed
because the victim in the case refused
to testify so it was dismissed and I
think that that's how we should leave
that it is interesting to me how deeply
his of his death has affected so many
different types of people why do you
think people are so deeply affected in
many cases by a man they did not know I
really think it's the idea that you
rooted for him or you didn't but that
was an emotion evoked the either way you
know what I keep thinking Lisa as often
as a case it was probably just another
ordinary day for them and then in
seconds your life is forever changed
ever changed it reminded me about the
quote about joy and sorrow are
inseparable and it's just that my sorrow
has been awakened in my life in their
lives in the world's lives